hello today we are going to talk about
the unsupervised machine learning method
called as hierarchical clustering
as you all know complex patterns in a
large data set are hard to find manually
these types of data show non-linear
dependencies and contain noise that make
makes it hard to find statistically
significant differences that's why we
turn to automated learning also known as
machine learning
this is when we train an algorithm or a
machine to perform tasks with data
looking for patterns
machine learning can be separated in two
main categories of methods
unsupervised machine learning and
supervised machine learning the
unsupervised machine learning focuses on
detection of patterns in data
the main idea is to separate data into
defined groups or clusters often times
we can explore the relationship between
the defined clusters and known
phenotypes to interpret the biological
association of samples in a cluster
now that the concept is clear let's try
to run several clustering methods and
see how they work
to run clustering on t bioinfo platform
you will need to upload the data of
expression that we generated from
processing the cell line data in the
last video
this data can be downloaded directly
from the lesson as well that is it that
is lesson number 13 in the
transcriptomics course on the
learn.mxlogic
portal clustering methods are located
under the data mining section on the tbi
info server
the tminfo platform has several types of
clustering methods p clustering for big
data hierarchical clustering k means
spec and db scan
in this course we will explore
hierarchical and k-means clustering both
of which are widely used for analysis of
rna-seq data
let's run radical clustering to see the
analysis output for the breast cancer
cell line data
the basic bottom up hierarchical
clustering algorithm is the edge cluster
module as in the other methods we have
been using in the course navigate to the
data mining unsupervised analysis area
then select file upload and use the
first button to directly upload your
file
start your pipeline and choose edge
class from the list of available
clustering algorithms
there are a number of parameters that
you can modify let's take a look at
those and explain what they mean
the first option is linkage
that indicates which approach is to be
used when calculating the possible
distance between points belonging to
different clusters for example single
finds the minimum possible distance
while complete find the maximum possible
distance
mean also referred to as average sums up
distances between all points found
between different clusters and takes the
mean average and centroid finds the
distance between centroids of each
cluster
distance indicates the mean by which
distance is statement a few options are
described here we will select what d2
clusters expected count number of
expected clusters based on previous
knowledge in our case we know that we
have four different sample subtypes in
our data based on the run table or two
groups from running the principal
component analysis
do transpose if you set 2 transpose to
false rows and columns at his genes and
samples will be switched and you will be
clustering genes
now we can just end the pipeline
give it an original undescriptive name
and then run the pipeline as previously
you may click on my pipelines and check
the status of your pipeline once it is
finished you can click on the name of
your pipeline to see the list of folders
and click the download pipeline to view
your
results you will get a dendrogram in
your results
now how do you analyze a dentogram or
study a dendrogram and also a pca
scatter plot that are the results of a
hierarchical clustering pipeline you may
visit lesson number 13
under the transcriptomics course on the
omixlogic portal which explains each and
every step very well and discusses in
further detail about the analysis of the
result